hello
and welcome to the reuben report direct
message i'm your host dave rubin
it's december 18 2020
and i'm pretending that i'm a network
news anchor how am i doing
i feel pretty good all right guys this
is
our last live direct message
of 2020 that's right i'm giving my guys
off for the remainder of the year we've
got a bunch of best dub
shows coming out over the next 10 days
or so
and i'll be at turning point student
action summit in florida giving a talk
on monday which we're going to post that
talk i'll be in front of live human
beings
my god what a world i haven't been in
front of live human beings at least
giving a talk
in front of a whole bunch of them while
holding a microphone
since literally one year ago at this
very same event so i'm super psyched to
be doing that
uh but my guys have been busting their
butts working really hard
all year the the team has expanded in
the midst of
lockdown actually the the two guys that
i have in studio right now not
not to get garcetti looking at me like i
have people in my room right now but
but michael and connor both are new
hires this year so our team
has expanded and everybody's worked
incredibly hard you know doing stuff
remote and now uh in a new studio right
we started in another studio this year
like just so many things so i want my
guys to
enjoy the christmas break and the end of
the year and actually one of the things
that
i write about in don't burn this book is
that if you're ever going to take
just a week off of social media that
christmas week basically rolling into
the new year's like that's kind of the
time
to do it right to focus on food family
friends remember those things so that's
what i'm mostly going to be doing i'm
really going to limit all my social
media stuff i'm going to be posting on
the reuben report community
so if you want to join us there i can
have a little more actually human
interaction with you guys there and as i
said we'll post a couple videos but
really i just want people to kind of
enjoy the end of the year so that that
is
my goal uh it's been a busy day already
though and i've i've got a busy day
ahead so we're we're ending strong i was
on outnumbered on fox
uh this morning already i think that was
at 9am was i on at 9am
and uh it's four lady hosts and they
bring in a guy i was the guy
uh this morning and that that was fun
and then i'm on uh with martha mccallum
a little bit later this afternoon and
we're gonna hit a couple stories here
and uh and then you know you'll go about
your way you know what i mean simple as
that oh by the way
i do have my trusty glasses today
because i may have to give
a special message for somebody
oh and one other thing before we get to
uh to the main meet of the show today uh
you know i talked about
uh having alopecia areata yesterday and
i showed some pictures of at one point i
had lost probably about 40
of my hair i went under these horrible
experimental treatments and just
awful awful stuff and i just want to say
i i got so many freaking messages
yesterday
from from many of you who not only have
dealt with alopecia
but have dealt with just like all sorts
of strange autoimmune
diseases that you chalk up to stress
that in many cases
doctors couldn't figure out exactly why
you were breaking out in hives or
having other kind of skin problems or
alopecia or whatever it is
and i just want to say that's exactly
why i try to do this show the way i do
it because as i always say i'm not
trying to make you crazy i'm not trying
to make you nervous or frantic
or psychotic or tense or any of those
things like i'm trying to do this stuff
in in a palatable way but it's also why
i started doing the august off the grid
thing uh where i take the month off
august it's why i think shutting it down
as we roll into christmas and
new year i think is important and i hope
you guys are just taking care of
yourselves however
you see fit uh but speaking of taking
care of yourselves we have governors
in this wonderful country democratic
governors people
like andrew cuomo in new york and gavin
newsom
in california and gretchen whitmer
in michigan and if you don't remember
gretchen whitmer she's the woman
who after a couple weeks of lockdown she
announced that people in michigan
should not do gardening and landscaping
outside of their homes
meaning on your own property she was
trying to get people to stop
planting plants okay literally trying to
stop people planting plants
you may not remember this but i actually
sent seeds to people in michigan we did
a little thing on twitter and i
sent seeds so people could plant tomato
plants cucumbers
i think we sent what else did we send we
sent some brussels sprouts somebody told
me they didn't want brussels sprouts
which made me send it to them
because i was like you know if you can't
i'm moving seeds here
you're going to take what you can get
anyway the point is she's a ridiculous
authoritarian lock down hoe and
uh lockdown oh i like that one
um but of course she doesn't abide by
her own rules
in the midst of the lockdown she was
seen uh on i believe it was on her boat
or a friend's boat
for her husband's birthday party with a
whole bunch of friends no social
distance thing and the rest of it
of course the hypocrisy knows no bounds
you guys know how
all of them flaunt their rules uh and
make you
the peons uh live under their boot
uh well gretchen whitmer uh she did a
zoom with some
children from michigan and uh and santa
claus
so i don't know how she got a hold of
santa claus he's very busy this time of
year but here is
governor gretchen whitmer santa claus
and the children of michigan thank you
for joining us i'm
governor gretchen whitmer and i'm really
excited
to be here with all of you and i also
know someone who's been really
following the rules and making sure that
he stays safe
and the elves stay safe and so my
special
guest is santa claus hello boys and
girls how
are you does anyone have a question for
santa claus
santa do you have to wear a mask when
i'm in my workshop
with all my elves we all are mashed up
in social distancing
okay hi sir i just captured you we
leave out cookies also some cherries for
the reindeer this year
yes please do set up carrots and cookies
if you can
also ultimate hand sanitizer if you're
done with the cookies and milk
that was a good suggestion excuse me
[Music]
everyone has been testing negative we're
still getting tested
i think we're so far up north that it
might not be getting to us but we're not
gonna take
any chances we're all gonna mask up
we're all gonna wash our hands and we're
all gonna stay
six feet apart
hi how can we keep people safe for
christmas
what i would suggest to do is what the
governor
is telling all the people of the great
state of michigan to do
social distance wash your hands
and make sure you wear your masks when
you're
outside your home and another way to
stay safe during the holiday
is to stay home but call your
grandparents and your cousins
and your family and it's the safest way
to tell the people you love how much you
care about them
this year it has to look a little bit
different so we can stay
safe and i appreciate all of you doing
your part
santa thank you so much for making time
for us today
let's hear your bust
merry christmas
bye everybody
excuse me i was vomiting that entire
time i don't
like you gretchen whitmer that whole
thing was so absolutely staggeringly
nauseating
okay there's so much there the first
question
the first question that a child has for
santa santa do you have to wear a mask
that's what the first question was
santa can i have a train santa can i
have a shotgun
santa can i have a new governor those
things all would have made sense
santa do you have to wear a mask then
he you see this moment where he tells
them that they all have to stand six
feet away from each other and then a
whole bunch of kids who were all
together probably about ten kids and a t
yes okay sarah
this is such ridiculous propaganda and
training children to be obedient
pets by adults who won't even behave by
their
own rules if you think for even
one moment that gretchen whitmer is
going to spend
christmas six feet away from everybody
not with anyone from her home or obeying
the rest
of the lockdown orders that she would
wish that these
children's parents would live under you
got another thing coming
and you know i haven't busted out the
old newsman glasses in a while right
i've busted them out i've talked about
bill de blasio special message
to andrew cuomo special message to eric
garcetti
special message to gavin newsom
but i haven't busted him out in a while
and people have said a lot of people
have said dave we wish you would bust
the glasses out more it's a very
important message you put the glasses on
and you take them off and you
talk directly to the camera and you lay
out a message for these people and i
haven't done it
because it's the holiday season and i've
been trying to you know not
curse as much and everything else but i
i just here we are and it's just you
know
gretchen whitmer
merry christmas could you be a little
bit better
i should have said it i should have said
it now i was trying to be nice i'm
trying to be nice here you see what
they've done
as a general rule i'm a pretty nice guy
and they've put me in a position of not
only am i now
a radical freedom extremist
but then i'm also saying these words
every now and again all right so that
was
graduate or merry christmas now i'll
just
michigan governor gretchen whitmer
go [ __ ] yourself
look joking aside this is just serious
drivel like this sort of training of
children
it's so dangerous and this has nothing
to do with what the government is
supposed to do
right like this is the government is
supposed to protect life liberty in the
pursuit of happiness it's just supposed
to
put the guard rails there so we're not
killing each other out on the streets
that's it and it's supposed to get out
of our way the idea that we're looking
to these people
as our role models or as people who
should be telling us what to do and when
to do it and who we can be with
and what we can eat and when we can eat
where we can go and all these things
it's just
absolutely crazy and i i hope that if
nothing else if you do nothing else
during christmas
you you spend the time with your loved
ones and people that you want to be with
and friends and family and all that and
and ignore these silly silly people
but let's talk a little bit more about
lockdowns because i've been saying
something for a couple weeks here that
now i see
bubbling up all over mainstream media
tucker was talking about it last night
on fox news chuck carlson of course
and a whole bunch of other people have
been bringing it up i hadn't heard
anyone saying and then i've
said it a couple times over the last few
weeks and i think i mentioned it
on on newsmax it may be on fox but one
of the very odd things to me about these
lockdowns
that we're told are so important is that
here in california we've been under
perpetual lockdown everyone's wearing a
mask everywhere yes
i did you know maya culpa guys i walked
the dog this morning
and i had an illegal haircut yesterday i
know i know
i'm a radical what can i tell you but
but what seems odd to me is
if if these lockdowns work well i am in
the most
locked down state here in california
florida is
open texas is basically open shouldn't
their numbers
be double triple exponentially
larger right exponentially more than the
numbers in the lockdown states if any of
this made sense now not everything is
apples to apples
california has a ton of people there's
weather things that are different but
also you could look at florida which has
an extremely elderly population i mean
there's all sorts of factors
but the point is that if locked out as a
general rule worked wouldn't we see that
lockdown states
would be going down and open states
would be going up and in fact we see the
reverse and it's partly because we're
not letting these
uh states that are locked down hit herd
immunity and a series of other things so
the federalists did an interesting piece
on this
and uh here's what they said thus far in
florida approximately 20 000 people have
died of covet 19.
in texas the number stands around 24 000
and in new york around 35 000. new york
is the smallest of the three
so it's the smallest of those three
states and it has the most numbers
with 19.54 million residents
then comes florida with 21.67
before texas with 28.7 million
restaurants
uh residents not restaurants there are
no restaurants left anymore
uh the reason that i said restaurants is
because uh we also got an interesting
number here
uh that according to new york state
1.4
1.43 of corona cases
in new york have been linked to
restaurants so
really think about this for a moment we
are telling people
stay out of restaurants not even outdoor
restaurants
sorry you built all that outdoor space
which isn't cheap and isn't easy to do
and you're already hurting financially
you can't go to restaurants even though
only roughly
one percent of the cases have anything
to do with restaurants
we're going to send you back home where
then they show according to their
numbers
people are getting more infected at home
because you're around family and friends
and everything else
again which i think you should be
allowed to do and as well within your
right and you should figure out
what works for you and your family and
if you have elderly people there or
infirmed people
or everything else there's no such thing
as a perfect system they can't keep you
perfectly
safe from an amorphous virus that
eight months ago we were told two weeks
to flatten the curve and then i watched
the infallible fouchy that's my new name
for him the infallible fouchy
uh who should really just be a a
magician doesn't it sounds like a major
now the infallible fouchy who will slice
this woman in half
i saw him this morning and he's talking
about how
by april after we have further lockdowns
and more masks and everything else by
april we can start thinking about
getting back to normalcy even though
now the vaccines are being taken i have
a friend in
in texas you know who you are who's a
doctor frontline worker and he got the
vaccine today
it is up to you in your own personal
life and with the choices that you think
are appropriate for you to figure
out if you want to take the vaccine or
not okay i mean it's just it's just as
simple as that but but getting to those
earlier numbers
new york has a smaller population than
florida or texas
not everything is equal i get that
but clearly the lockdowns don't work
there's no science behind it yesterday
we did the story out of san diego where
a judge
looked at the science he looked at the
science and he said guess what we got to
open up the strip clubs because there's
no science to say these things can be
uh should be closed okay so we're really
getting to this sort of breaking point
where some states are going to be free
and some states are not going to be free
and speaking of
free states as i said at the top of the
show i'm heading out this weekend
to florida i'm going to go see what free
people i feel like i'm going to another
country i mean we've really
reduced this lunacy that i feel like
when i go to florida
which i've been to many many times and
i've always liked florida and i don't
mind the humidity
that i'm going to be in another country
i'm going to get off the plane and i'm
going to see people
and they might be hugging each other or
talking to each other and i might go to
a restaurant and order
french fries i don't know maybe i'll
have a burger
a steak who knows well it's florida i'm
probably have a lot of fish
i like fresh fish and i'm gonna have
that in florida and you can't stop me
gretchen whitmer andrew cuomo or gavin
newsom
anyway it's all just silly nonsense uh
let's just do one other
story on uh covid before i wrap up our
last live stream
of the year you guys may remember the
newspaper formerly known as the new york
times it was once thought of
as the paper of record in the united
states and really now
if you have a bird parakeet whatever it
might be
the really the best thing you could use
the new york times for is to line the
cage it really has no other
purpose besides that i suppose if you
were doing paper mache do people still
do that
whatever you do with paper mache and you
can create some sort of sculpture or
something you could use
the new york times for that but the new
york times is a crap factory
of fake news and drivel they've called
me alt-right they've written hit pieces
around
a ton of people that i know we know they
constantly lie about anyone that's a
conservative
and they they cover the the crimes and
and
drivel that that comes out of the
progressive left they've completely
wholly embraced
uh identity politics a moderate liberal
like barry weiss had to resign from the
new york times because it has become
such a cancerous
awful organization i know a couple other
people that are
loosely affiliated with the new york
times some of them that are actually
there
that that are constantly talking about
how horrible it is so the new york times
is a shitty shitty organization and it
and it's indicative
of how the news and mainstream media has
just absolutely crumbled
well they did a piece this morning and
the title of the article in the new york
times is
the elderly verse essential workers who
should get the first
who should get corrupt let me start that
again the elderly
verse essential workers who should get
the coronavirus
vaccine first now that's an interesting
title for an article and there's an
interesting
i would say moral and ethical debate
about who should get the
vaccine first right we've got frontline
workers and bus drivers and delivery
people and doctors and nurses and
everything else we've got
you know who generally are younger and
they're putting themselves out there so
they're more at risk but they might have
stronger
defenses against it and everything else
so maybe we do that
and get to them first maybe we don't
then we have elderly people
who we know are dying at a higher rate
and are more at risk so maybe we want to
do it there
and we have to figure out where
resources go great moral and ethical
debate right
but here's how the new york times framed
it this is just so spectacular
quote harold schmidt
an expert in ethics and health policy at
the university of pennsylvania
said that it is reasonable to put
essential workers ahead of
older adults given their risks and now
here's where it gets good
and that they are disproportionately
minorities
older populations are whiter dr schmidt
said
society is structured in a way that
enables them to live
longer instead of giving additional
health benefits to those who already
had more of them we can start to level
the playing field
a bit did you catch what he just said
there did you catch what schmidt just
said there
i can tell you this uh ethics ain't what
they used to be and i don't know what
the hell is going on at university of
pennsylvania
in essence he is saying because there
are some frontline workers who happen to
be minorities
we should let grandma and grandpa whitey
right old white people they should just
die
do you see how what he framed there is
so different than what i framed before
that if you want to have the ethical
debate about frontline workers versus
older people and how to figure out
resources well that's just fine
but once you put color ethnicity into
the mix
level the playing field that is the most
dangerous phrase
that i've ever heard related to all of
this because what he means is
yeah more of them should die more white
people should die and by the way if
you're thinking that this is shocking
this is just the end of what identity
politics is
identity politics is not about raising
certain people
based on skin color it's about taking
down other people
and it literally the end of identity
politics
is either killing whitey grandma and
grandpa or having laws
that will be against white people it
really is as simple as that it is as
simple as that if you take this thing to
its logical conclusion and and i'd like
to give a special shout out to you
losers at media matters who are
undoubtedly watching this and gonna
selectively clip what i just said there
but that is
the truth they go on to say in the
article still
or he goes on to say still some people
believe it is
wrong to give racial and socioeconomic
equity
more weight than who is most likely to
die
holy fuckballs man you're a horrible
person harold schmidt
university of pennsylvania should be
absolutely embarrassed and you you have
no
understanding of ethics yes
who will die should absolutely have more
weight
than the racial and socioeconomic equity
of a group of people take a breath dave
okay you get it guys you get it this
this is what we're fighting
and uh as i as i wrap
this last direct message of 2020 uh let
me just say that
this is going to continue this stuff is
going to continue because it has to get
to whatever it's awful sort of horrific
rock bottom thing is and it just isn't
there yet and that i think is the
unanswered question and maybe that will
be the question
of 2021 maybe the real question of 2021
is
now that wokeness has just burst forth
into the disgusting grotesque
anti-american anti-freedom
anti-capitalist thing that it is
now that more people get it instead of
just the fringe youtubers and you crazy
people who watch us
instead of that maybe now that more
people see it it eventually will get
it will destroy so much that is good
it will destroy companies ability to
hire qualified people it will
it will harm every governmental agency
because we'll be hiring transportation
secretaries
because they're gay rather than they
know what they're doing and the litany
of other things
that you guys know about right that i
don't have to talk ad nauseam about
maybe 2021 will be the year that it all
comes crashing down on itself i actually
felt that 2020
could have been that year but then covet
complicated things in a way that
obviously
nobody fully understood um all right on
that note
folks uh this was officially my last
in studio live stream for 2020. i have
told my guys you're not gonna believe
this guys i have here
an electronic telephone with a video
camera on it
and uh over the course of the next 10
days i will
maybe i'll do some live streams i may do
some random ones
maybe from the beach walking down the
beach i'm going to be in florida trying
to enjoy myself
maybe eating some nice fresh fish who
knows but i will be spending all of my
social media time
on the reuben report community so you
can go to reubenreport.com if you want
to join and and we can
share thoughts and share food and
recipes and music and all the other
pictures of family and all that good
stuff and i really do love connecting
with you guys
uh reminder though we do have one more
sit down for the year
my last interview of the year is with
adam carolla where we're going to just
recap
everything that happened in 2020. he's
on that short list that i always talk
about of sane people
so we will recap the craziest year of my
lifetime and one of the craziest years
in american history
by the way part three of my interview
with abigail schreier all about the the
sudden
burst of trans of young girls
who are transitioning uh that's up right
now on youtube in the full part uh the
full interview i should say
is at rubinreport.com and then we've got
a couple year-end compilations one is
just all my appearances on other shows
and
and then the other is uh interviews that
i did here
that's that's pretty much it that's
pretty much it so my final message to
you guys if
uh as my as we shut down here is uh
love each other love your families be
with your families and your friends
i know it can be tough i've got versions
of it myself as i keep telling you guys
um try to cool it on on the political
thing
uh during this time of year it's like we
got a lot to be thankful for
and uh merry christmas to you guys
last day of hanukkah technically last
night was the last candle but i guess
it rolls into sundown today and i look
forward to seeing you guys in florida i
will be at turning point
student action summit on monday i'll be
doing a couple interviews
and uh we'll see what else happens so oh
and just more than anything else just
just thank you guys for being part of
this adventure this year i mean what a
wacky year we have all had
and everyone it everyone you know you
there were two ways to end this year
right you either kind of went completely
nuts
or or you lined some things up in life
right like you started like figuring
things out or you just sort of went
went down with the ship and uh and i'm
proud to say that
i think we've done something really good
here you know we launched this show i
wasn't even doing this show
at the beginning of the year we just
launched this show in september as i
said the team has expanded
uh locals is absolutely crushing it i
think we're fighting big tech
in a really effective good way and i'm
just proud of what's going on and it's
all because of you guys so thank you
guys merry christmas
happy new year and i'll see you
in 2021